[Music]
politicians tell us that we can trust
them because they are transparent
they're upfront about their dealings
so we took a look at all of the
information that MPS put in the public
domain put it all together in one place
and then had a very close look at it so
that we could see where their claims
match reality and we've given you the
ability to do the same at home
[Music]
so we're going to use together with our
partners at tortoise media just wanted
to understand better how money flows
through our political systems what the
Westminster accounts does is bring
together multiple confusingly presented
information sources in one website
accessible on your computer or on your
phone to allow you to trace the impact
of money in politics whether it's how
much MPS own or who donates or how
business gets its way this tool will
lift the lead on what's Happening
who's earning the most amongst MPS is
yours on the top 20 which is headed by
Theresa May he's told us who's giving
the most to MPS and do we really
understand where that cash is coming
from and it also tells us where business
focus is how they use the place behind
me in order to try and get their way in
Westminster all of that and more
discoverable because of the tool that
you'll be able to use as part of the
Westminster accounts
foreign
[Music]
months trying to decipher and decode
information from MPS to put it in our
database and what you find is it's still
not always clear what's going on what
you also find is when you ask them they
don't always want to give you an answer
which is why you and we will keep coming
back to the tortoise media Sky News
Westminster Accounts at all because it's
only by looking at what they're saying
thinking about what it tells us we ever
be able to truly trust our politics